mais d'abord des passagers de la ligne
rayenire entre tour et Marrakech au
Maroc encore traumatisé 146 passagers
qui étaient en vacances ou partir rendre
visite à leur famille mais quand la
terre a tremblé dans la nuit de vendredi
à samedi le séjour a tourné au cauchemar
des maisons détruites et des morts 3000
selon un dernier décomte face à cette
catastrophe nombreux sont ceux encore
aujourd'hui traumatisé d'autres veulent
déjà repartir pour aider à la
reconstruction Lucas chopa
tous sont soulagés de fouler le sol
français 4 jours après le séisme qui a
fait près de 3000 morts au Maroc 146
passagers en provenance de Marrakech ont
atterri ce matin à tour beaucoup sont
encore sous le choc en étant et en
vivant au Maroc à Casablanca je précise
qui est loin de de l'endroit du séisme
j'avais
l'impression de mourir ma compagne est
encore sous le choc euh
le simple un simple bruit dans la nuit
l'éveil et à cours dans les escaliers
vous avvez un peu bouche aux oreilles
quoi
et pas je vois pas un peu le vertige on
va dire dit c'est quoi qu'est-ce qui se
passe là et après je vois les gens qui
sortent de de partout entre un crayon
trbl de terre TR de terre quoi j'étais
obligé de de retourner à marrakeche pour
pour aller à l'aéroport et ben j'ai
passé de nuits à
marrakeche le doigt dans l'avion aussi
une poignée de touristes pas prêt
d'oublier leur séjour ça a duré bien de
bonnes minutes donc on a eu bien le
temps de s'en rendre compte de se poser
la question entre nous de ce qui se
passait on était en train de s'endormir
en plus donc ça nous a bien réveillé on
a entendu beaucoup les ambulances dehors
pour le coup ensuite on est tous sortis
et on a décidé avec tous les gens qui
étaient autour de nous de dormir dehors
mais si l'émotion est forte beaucoup
soulligne une magnifique solidarité sur
place le séisme ça a été une une belle
catastrhe mais quelque chose qui a
montré aussi de belles choses en fait
c'est malheureux que on attende qu'il
arrive des choses comme ça pour montrer
la solidarité du peuple des gens ma
grandmère qui va déjà qui va y aller moi
aussi jeour pour pour aider du coup par
y en a qui on tout perdu en fait les
villages entiers on été détruit pour le
moment le séisme marocain n'a pas
perturbé les liaisons avec tour l'avion
est aussitôt reparti pour Marrakech